la ribote c'est ça quand il comme un
chanteur est en bouillie de
l'association pages en pages passe de
maison en maison pour chanter noël et
les familles qui accueillent le petit
groupe voit tout préparé pathé bout de
jambon sans oublier les boissons pour
régaler tout le monde ceux qui reçoivent
normalement met à disposition les os
maison sans sens on connaît a demandé
est-ce qu'on peut passer au père et ça
fait toujours plaisir aux personnes
âgées aux parents à mes parents qui ont
actuellement à fait mon pays
qu'actuellement le grâce à déplacer et
il est toujours très très très heureux
dans les voitures noires et les tables
sont déjà prêtes tout est sur la table
justement recevoir tous les convives ont
fait tous les chantiers en tout ce qu'il
faut là remote yvelines habite la
réunion enfants du quartier carabins aux
lorrains cela fait 50 ans qu'elles
n'avaient pas vécu cette ambiance de
ribaute on chantait noël les petites
filles surtout les challenges et est
comme elle est on est né là-dedans on a
grandi là dedans on connaît l'autre tic
par terre et puis vient l'heure du
départ pour rejoindre une autre maison
nous allons donner de l'amour aux
habitants du quartier se sont exilés
comme ça parce que c'est la famille et
les amis
et puis des amis de d'autres communes
qui nous ont rejoints puis ce qu'ils
aiment notre joie de vivre et nous
allons partager cette joie de vivre
depuis 6h du matin le groupe page en
page est en action et sur son parcours
il a fait une halte à l'anniversaire de
noé lise martin elle est lassante
aujourd'hui c'est la docteure pour moi
il est secondaire
et puis j'ai envie ni chanter nouvelle
banque
[Musique]
un moment vraiment un bel âge et ça me
fait plaisir l'habile des culs et a une
bonne mémoire elle même on arrive à nous
faire part que ce soit elle a une bonne
mémoire l on retient tout lé c'est une
femme des votes à travers la martinique
les ribotte vont se poursuivre jusqu'à
l'épiphanie
je